bonsoir vasselle vous suivez ces
manifestations pour nous et ces
féministes en ont gros sur le coeur et
elles sont toujours là a priori
[Musique]
effectivement elle en avait gros sur le
coeur un rassemblement qui a commencé à
partir de 18 heures à l'appel de
plusieurs collectifs dont le collectif
des étudiants de féministes de paris 1
le collectif nous tout comme vous pouvez
voir dernièrement et toujours sur le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville ça s'est
dispersé il ya à peu près une petite
demi-heure donc la manifestation a
touché sa façon rester trois heures sur
ce parvis avec des slogans hostiles à
gérald darmanin et puis à eric dupond
moretti après leur nomination après le
remaniement le premier au ministère de
l'intérieur second à la justice et à
monsieur darmanin qui est accusé de viol
donc c'est le slogan qui revenait très
souvent très souvent un violeur à
l'intérieur et puis un complice à la
justice des slogans hostiles à ces deux
personnalités qui ont été nommés au
gouvernement elle demande mais tout
simplement qu'il soit démis de leurs
fonctions je vous propose d'écouter
quelques réactions qu'on a pu recueillir
ici sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
c'est important pour moi mais c'est tout
pour moi ça devrait être important tout
pour tous
barthez en fait on est on à faire un
ministre qui était accusé de quelque
chose alors je suis pas en train de dire
que il l'est mais il accusé en tous les
cas et on l'a nommé à un poste qui fait
de lui en fait le chef de tous les
policiers de france plein d'amis à qui
arrivent des histoires similaires aient
acquis qu'on n'écoute pas assez dans des
situations de violences de harcèlement
de viol et je me suis vraiment dit que
c'était le moment de venir un peu fins
avec le symbole il est pas très très
cool
il doit pas y avoir de de présomption
d'innocence ou quoi que ce soit enfin il
est donc oui je suis là parce que ça me
choque un peu mais je pense que à ce
stade là il faut qu'on fasse bloc
je pense aussi qu'il faut qu'on refasse
ce converger les luttes de plus en plus
clairement au niveau de la communication
au niveau politique le message que ça
renvoie aux fans et aux victimes est un
très mauvais message en fait voilà c'est
important d'être unis face à ce genre de
questions parce que c'est important
d'être solidaire des femmes
qu'est-ce qu'on est dense aujourd'hui on
dénombre fait qu'un violeur a été nommé
premier flic de france le gant ici son
parvis de l'hôtel de ville mais ils ont
plusieurs villes de france aujourd'hui
pour alerter le gouvernement sur ces
deux nominations un appel aussi pour
lutter encore pour les droits des femmes
elles sont restés ici pendant trois
heures et puis elles ont déclaré
continuer le mouvement continuer la
lutte une la lutte tant que le
gouvernement ne répondra pas
favorablement à leurs revendications à
savoir la démission de ses deux
nouvelles personnalités politiques merci
beaucoup à faire pour toutes ces
précisions ben hassen chébili en direct
de des manifestations féministes à paris